hi my name is Tamika lamisil and I've
been a screenwriter for about 15 years
I'm also a writer director producer and
my background is acting my very first
screenplay was written back in 1998 it
was inspired by a true event and New
York City it's sort of a pre 9/11
romanticized version of New York City
and some of the things that I loved
about the city and some of the people
and events that took place there and one
of the things that happened I was a poet
at the time as well and my book bag got
stolen and it had like everything in it
it had my poetry and it had
unrecoverable poetry because it was all
hand written in a journal and it had my
personal journal it had photos all kinds
of private and personal information and
I was really devastated really mostly
about the poetry so I knew I was never
gonna get that back and I decided to
turn the incident into something
positive by writing a screenplay about
it and I got really lucky because that
script you know sort of validated me won
a lot of awards like the Gordon Parks
independent awards and ten thousand
dollars through the IFP independent film
project and I was really great and some
other really amazing things and
interesting things happen with that
script but we will get back to that in
the interim I wrote another script
called memoirs of a virgin and
that's sort of I've been tweaking and
working on that for a few years now and
won the Disney Fellowship and but it's
been really challenging getting that
script made from script to screen and
part of what I believe is the issue is
because it's a little racy at least back
about five or six years ago when I wrote
it now I think the timing is a little
bit better and people are more open to
projects that are controversial that
have to do with sexuality
religion and also that are commercial so
that's the script that I'm working on
now that I'm really excited about I
really want to see that script made
because I think it's a really important
discussion especially when it comes to
women to talk about how religion impacts
our sexual choices and religion and
guilt and and all of that so and it's a
coming-of-age story in that realm so I'm
very excited about about that script and
I've when I write I usually write during
the I call it the nocturnal vampire
hours between like 12 a.m. and 4 a.m. I
used to go to coffee shops around the
city but now I just write at home
because the hours that I keep
screenwriting has really taught me that
you have to have perseverance passion
patience because some of those scripts
that you've written three or four years
ago or even ten years ago for that
matter still have relevance and
sometimes it's just a timing issue
so you know stand by your work continue
to tweak it work on it and and be
patient and continue to write and I feel
like if you do all of those things that
you definitely will be successful what I
really want to happen with my scripts I
want them to be produced
I have sell scripts that I'd like to
direct some I don't want to direct but I
really want to see see them produced I
want to continue to create product
continue to write continue to make a
difference with my work as well now back
to my Hollywood story of jar by the door
and jar by the door the first script
that I wrote was optioned several times
and eventually it was sold for six
figures woohoo yay me but a little while
after I got the check we realized that
it was you know rubber that it was never
gonna be made good and I was really
devastated by that I mean these people
had bought options so it seemed like
everything was going to happen you know
like clockwork I was even gonna get to
direct it it was anime
amazing situation and the check just
never was made good I still have that
check by the way and after that happened
I realized that I wanted to do more with
my art to make a difference
so I created a nonprofit organization
called make a film foundation so I'd
like to make a wish
but we make films with kids who have
serious or life-threatening medical
conditions and we help them to create
short film legacies by teaming them with
famous people in the industry so they
essentially get to write and star in
their own short films documentaries or
narratives with famous people in
Hollywood and amazing wonderful
directors and we've had an opportunity
to work with Academy award-winning or
nominated directors and actors and
writers it's been amazing so I actually
wouldn't change anything as far as my
Hollywood story because it was the the
non sale sale of that script that
actually gave me the impetus and the
kick in the butt to create my nonprofit
make a film foundation so yeah I think
that about sums it up I mean I I want to
write I want to direct I want to do all
of that stuff but as far as these
particular scripts are concerned I
really want to see them they're still my
favorite two scripts I've written about
20-25 scripts but these are really close
to my heart for very particular reasons
one is the first one that I wrote and it
has a lot of story and behind it as far
as the things that have happened with it
and didn't happen with it and the other
one I just feel is really really
relevant and there is some personal some
personal stuff in there that inspired me
to write that as well so thank you and I
hope to see you at the movies watching
my films soon